toneladas de basura apiladas por las
calles debido a las huelgas de los
recolectores en Francia que participan
en las protestas contra el proyecto de
aumento de la edad de jubilación general
de 62 a 64 años
por un lado entiendo el movimiento
social del lado de los basureros
por otro lado Sí deja las calles en un
estado que no es no están en las mejores
condiciones
la huelga ha afectado algunas de las
zonas más exclusivas de París como los
distritos 5-6 y 16 otros lugares son
atendidos por empresas privadas que no
se han declarado en huelga la agencia de
residuos domésticos de la capital
sickton ha desviado los camiones de
basura a otros centros de almacenamiento
y tratamiento de la región y aún no ha
recurrido a la policía Tres plantas
incineradoras de las afueras de la
capital se han visto afectadas por los
paros algunas personas están preocupadas
por la imagen de la ciudad
excepto los turistas creo que todo el
mundo entiende situación pero es cierto
que los turistas se escandalizan un poco
sobre todo porque París tiene fama de
ser sucia pero Este es otro nivel
los basureros y conductores pueden
jubilarse actualmente a partir de los 57
años pero se enfrentarían a otros dos
años de trabajo en virtud de los planes
de reforma según el sindicato cgt el
mismo sindicato sostiene que la
esperanza de vida de los basureros es
entre 12 y 17 años inferior a la media
del conjunto del país
aún no hay fecha fija para poner fin a
la huelga